كيف نتخلص من الصداع في رمضان حسب نصائح
الاطباء اولا ضروره تناول الطعام الصحي
والمتوازن الذي يجب ان يحتوي على
البروتينات والدهون الصحيه وكميات كافيه
من الكربوهيدرات والسكر وايضا النشويات لا
يجب ايضا التهاون في شرب الماء وذلك
بمقدار عشره اكواب على الاقل الى جانب
السوائل الصحيه بكميه كافيه خلال وجبتي
الافطار والسحور كما يدعو الاطباء الى عدم
اهمال وجبه السحور كونها ضروريه جدا
بالنسبه للصائم حيث تمد الجسم بالطاقه
التي يحتاج اليها خلال ساعات الصوم
الطويله ويفضل تجنب تناول الحلويات خلال
الافطار والحد من تناول العصائر المحلاه
كذلك بالتاكيد ضروره النوم لعدد ساعات
كافن والافضل الا تقل عن سبع ساعات يوميا
حتى يتفادى الصائم الارق والاجهاد